[Music]
Phoebe hey hey look maybe he wanted to
hang out
last summer is so great and your
characters have such great chemistry
together but I'm curious to know did you
know each other before you started this
move we should just start telling people
that we did I if we grew up together
yeah we grew up together in Australia
actually brother and sister had you
watched Riverdale before yes yeah I had
thoughts thoughts on Riverdale yeah it's
a great series
it's an excellent series very good innit
you see what she says when the cameras
aren't rolling in KJ had you watch the
Fosters are good trouble yes I've seen
but I have bits of pieces I don't mean
I'm not finding them yeah well we know
that you're not actually brother and
sister but how did you guys find that
off-screen connection that translated to
your on-screen bond just kind of heaven
just work she's from Australia I'm from
New Zealand we're from a similar part of
the world it was easy to kind of get
that chemistry go so what's the diligent
thieves we haven't talked about it yeah
keeping the mystery alive
I'm digging man what is the most
romantic thing you guys have done for a
significant other I don't feel
comfortable giving my answers because
it's like my thing you know what MA and
sometimes I reuse my thing oh so I don't
want I don't want well now you have
those yeah but no one's gonna know what
it is okay Maya what's the most romantic
thing you've done or had done for you
this past year I had my 25th birthday
and my man friend who surprised me and
flew my mom from Australia uh and so his
alarm kept going off one morning and I
was like it's Saturday so I wanted to
sleep in and I was annoyed and then my
mom walked into my bedroom and I was
like that's really sweet so she was here
for my 25th which was I was very
romantic
he's more romantic than I am
yeah well thank you Jay since you won't
tell us what your romantic gesture is
what is the most sweet thing that
someone has done for you probably the
sweetest thing that someone has done for
me
a lady friend that I once had snuck into
work and decorated my whole trailer on
Valentine's Day
the whole thing had been decorated oh do
you guys have a favorite rom-com that
you could watch over and over for
Christmas is Christmas is what what is
it about that movie oh I just love it I
love it I see it probably every month it
just kind of recharges my batteries and
it makes me ready to go and spies me a
lot Vince Vaughn probably one of my
favorite actors I mean easily get yeah
yeah yeah how do we was a Guy in 10 days
yeah what was the one scene that was the
most difficult for you guys to film
because you kept busting up laughing too
much probably the yeah we can't laughing
right now mostly because we had
literally just shot the same way we'd
eaten the ribs before that it was the
least sexy thing some ribs
bloated smelly doesn't get any worse
than that
yeah so the behind-the-scenes secrets of
that super sexy adorable seem not sex
not sexy at all not sexy building sexy
but not tasty yeah those it looks sexy
no idea that you guys were fooling that
one yeah well now you know any other
behind-the-scenes secrets about that
scenes that fans should know how were
the ribs the roots were great like the
first take and then you know it's kind
of all but they were tasty why do you
feel like fans of good trouble in
Riverdale are gonna like the last summer
hmm I think for a lot of reasons we have
an amazing cast we have some really
really funny and sad and really romantic
moments in the film and I think
everyone's gonna be able to relate to it
even if you've already made this
decision you know of what you want to do
after the last summer before graduation
or if it's a decision you made in the
past I think most people can relate to
one last summer the last chance to go
all in
I mean what's there to lose right
[Music]